because humans our story gathers because
we share stories by drums talking across
distances in novels and movies and now
on cell phones because we gather in
circles around the fire whether it's
outside at a ceremonial ground a trash
crack can in the hardcore part of the
city or in the kitchen around the stove
to hear because the best stories break
our hearts over and over again and we
emerge together drenched in knowledge
and have to tell this story again one
more time because together we are this
road of longing and becoming because
tonight we are here together to honor
the story of Wes Studi
Cherokee citizen yang
Mazar in the house and this is Indian
country red studi raised in some of the
most beautiful country of trees stones
and water where nearly everyone speaks
Cherokee because Wes Studi story doesn't
fit into stereotypes in which a native
man can only be a rough Savage or a
charismatic medicine man
zowie natives in this country are more
than five hundred and seventy-three
Nations and we are horn players family
raisers astronauts poets and some of us
are actors because Wes Studi went to
Shalako Indian school went to Vietnam as
a warrior and returned to be a warrior
in the struggle for native rights we did
not have the legal right to practice our
cultural ways until 1978 because he
eventually made his way to LA to become
an actor even sleeping on Bob Hicks
couch as did most native actors at one
time or the other as he became one of
the most accomplished native actors of
our times because an actor is a
transformer becomes the story if you
haven't lived it it won't come out of
your horns to Charlie Parker and vinarov
bebop jazz whose mother was Choctaw
because in this shimmering punchy field
of story making we know Wes studious
girl crazy stud the toughest Pawnee a
Mirage in the California desert high
ranking Huron warrior a sheriff a
powerful arms dealer the most famous
tracker of his day a detective chief Red
Cloud Avenger mercenary hijacker pompous
movie director trainer of inept
superheroes
a base commander on Jupiter's moon Io
bingo caller Navajo detective veteran
smokejumper Foreman who can follow fire
without modern technology a jailed boxer
cell-made a shaman a priest who has
hidden a piece of Thor's hammer
jack-of-all-trades auto mechanic
medicine man demon prophet a DJ bounty
hunter tribal council member president
of the USA counselor war warriors more
chiefs a werewolf a police captain no
angels are Saints and more because we
have watched admired been entranced as
you transform and in doing so transform
the story of all of us because we know
West's duty to be consummate artist
lover of community bearer of story and
friend as you will see in this video of
celebration